,
qui arrive dans le contexte de
la COP 15. Mathieu Prost nous
donne les ililils.
- Trois hectares supplémentaires
pour un parc qui en couvre déjà
227, c'est un agrandissement
CAROLINE BOURGEOIS, Comité
exécute e e la Ville de Montréal
- Chaque pied carré compte dans
notre ville. On va déminéraliser
- Dès 2024, les abords de
aiaiaison Smith ressembleront
un peu plus au décor original.
Sur les quelque 725 placesetetet
de la montagne, 300 serontsuppre
à une clairière. On promet
d'améliorer l'accèsmmmmmmmmmmmm.
- Déjà, je suis venue il y a
quelques week-ends, puis...
pendant le temps des couleurs,
puis il y avait des line-ups.
si on peut prendre le transport
en commun, il y a pas de
problème. Ceux qui viennent
de l'extérieur de la ville,
c'est peut-être un peu moins
le fun
mairesse de Montréal
- On va se dire les vraiesafafa,
on parle de crise
environnementale, donc là,
on fait quoi? On
de chaleur ou encourager un îlt
de fraîcheur où est-ce qu'on va
soutenir la biodiversité.
- Dans les 20 prochaines années,
Québec va aussi céder à Montr
Royal Victoria, comme
ce stationnemesisisisiment
abandonné, mais il faudra
attendre 2033, car il sert à à .
Un horizon un peu trop loi
pour certains.EMEMEMEMEMMANUEL l
région. environnement, Montréal
- Moi, jieieieieieieieieieieieie
trouver des actions, peut-être
même temporaires, mais qui vont
permettre de commencer
àsecteurs.
- Avec une nouvelle entrée
par la rue University, le poumon
vert de Montréal devrait être
le centre-ville.
Dr DAVID KAISER, Direction
régionale santé publique de Mtl
- Et lorsque toutes et tous y
nos parcs sont des leviers
extrêmement puissants
pour réduire les inégalités
et des piliers de l'adaptation
- La pandémie a rendu le Mont-
Royal encore plus populaire.
On compte aujourd'hui près
de 4inininininininininininininie
danger pour la biodiversité.
La Ville a pour objectif
d'en fermer et d'en reboiser
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canadl.l.l.l.l.